>> Emily: THE NFL IS DRAWING A
LINE IN THE STAND TO GET MORE
PLAYERS VACCINATED.
THE LEAGUE SAYS THEY WON'T
EXTEND THE SEASON OVER
UNVACCINATED PLAYERS.
IF A GAME IS NOT RESCHEDULED,
THE TEAM WITH THE OUTBREAK MAY
HAVE TO FORFEIT.
THAT MEANS NEITHER TEAM GETS
PAID.
THE TEAM RESPONSIBLE WILL COVER
ANY FINANCIAL LOSSES AND COULD
PHASE DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
THE "NEW YORK POST" SUMS IT UP
WITH THIS HEADLINE.
"NFL VAX OR LOSE."
THAT SAYS IT ALL.
>> Raymond: I SPOKE TO AN NFL
PLAYER.
THERE'S A LOT OF UNHAPPINESS IN
LOCKER ROOMS OVER THIS AND THEY
GO BACK TO TRAINING CAMP.
A LOT OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
PLAYERS ARE SAYING I DON'T WANT
THIS VACCINE.
WHETHER THEY'RE CULTURAL
BLOCKADES THERE OR WHETHER IT'S
A DEEPLY HELD BELIEF, THAT
SHOULD BE UP TO THEM.
TO DENY A WHOLE TEAM -- BECAUSE
REMEMBER, THE RULE IS IF YOU'RE
UNVACCINATED AND COVID SPREADS,
YOU NOT ONLY FORFEIT THE GAME
BUT YOU LOSE YOUR SEED PLAYOFF
SPACE.
THE WHOLE TEAM SUFFERS.
PLAYERS ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
I THINK IT'S VERY COMPLICATED.
THE NFL HAS TO BACKTRACK ON
THIS.
THIS IS A DRACONIAN MEASURE AND
THEY DID NOT CONSULT WITH THE
PLAYERS.
>> Emily: KAYLEIGH?
>> Haleigh: YEAH, I DON'T
BELIEVE IN MANDATES BY
COMPANIES, BY THE GOVERNMENT.
I BELIEVE IN PERSONAL CHOICE.
I HAVE GIVEN THE REASONS WHY MY
PERSONAL CHOICE WAS TO GET
VACCINATED.
I BELIEVE THE VACCINE CREATED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAVED A LOT OF
LIVES AND I FEEL CONFIDENT BEING
AROUND THE ELDERLY NOW.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS
PUNITIVE.
IT'S BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR
DOCTOR.
WHEN AN EMPLOYER GETS INVOLVED
LIKE THIS, THREATENS TO PUNISH,
LOSE GAMES, TAKE AWAY PAY, IT'S
OVER THE LINE.
MOST AMERICANS WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT.
>> Emily: ABBY, RAYMOND BRINGS
UP A GREAT POINTS.
WHERE IS THE NFLPA ON THIS?
THIS IS A HEAVILY UNIONIZED
LEAGUE HERE.
SO IT'S INTERESTING THAT AS HE
PUT IT, THIS DRACONIAN MEASURE
EVEN PASSED.
>> Abby: YEAH, WE'LL SEE MORE
PLAYERS COME OUT AGAINST THIS.
THEY ARE VERY POWERFUL
ORGANIZATION.
THEY'RE THE VOICE FOR THE
PLAYERS.
KAYLEIGH SAID IT BEST.
THIS IS ABOUT LESS OF A FIGHT OF
GETTING VACCINATED AND MORE OF A
FIGHT OF CHOOSING.
I BRING UP DeANDRE HOPKINS.
HE SAID, YOU KNOW, HE'S
QUESTIONING HIS FUTURE IN THE
NFL AFTER THIS POLICY.
HE CITED IN ANOTHER TWEET THAT
BECAUSE HIS GIRLFRIEND'S BROTHER
SUFFERED HEART ISSUES AFTER
GETTING THE VACCINE.
THAT IS YET TO BE PROVEN AS I'M
SURE MORE INVESTIGATION INTO
THAT.
BUT YOU CAN'T NECESSARILY PUNISH
PLAYERS FOR MAKING THE CHOICE TO
DO THIS.
IT PUTS EVERYONE IN A BAD
POSITION, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
CAN BE RESPONSIBLE FOR NEITHER
TEAM GETTING PAID.
IT'S LIKE GOING TO PRACTICE,
BEING LATE AND MAKE EVERYBODY
ELSE RUN SPRINTS AND HAVING TO
WATCH THEM.
IT'S A TOUGH SITUATION.
>> Raymond: WHAT IF A VACCINATED
PLAYER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SPREAD?
WE'VE SEEN THE DELTA VARIANT
MOVE AROUND ON VACCINATED.
IS THE NFL EPIDEMIOLOGISTS?
THIS IS TOUGH.
>> Emily: IT'S WHETHER OR NOT
THEY TEST POSITIVE.
TO THE POINT THAT ABBY BROUGHT
UP.
THE FORFEITURE AND NONPAYMENT
CLAUSE IS FROM OLD RULES SO
WE'RE INCLUDING OLD RULES AND
FIT IT IN TO THE SITUATION ON
COVID AND THE NEW POLICY THAT
THEY HAVE.
WHAT A MESS TO SAY THE LEAST.
>> Martha: WHAT A MESS.
IT'S THIS WAY WITH COMPANIES,
SCHOOLS, UNIVERSITIES, SPORTS
TEAMS.
THIS IS THE ISSUE FOR THE FALL.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE REASONS FOR NOT
WANTING IT.
THE OTHER THING IS, THEY SHOULD
BE DOING ANTI-BODY TESTING.
IF YOU CAN PROVE THE ANTI-BODIES
TO THE VIRUS, SHOULD BE THE
EQUIVALENT OF GETTING THE
VACCINE.
THIS IS BASED ON DOCTORS THAT I
HAVE SPOKEN WITH THAT MAKE A
VERY GOOD ARGUMENT FOR THIS.
THAT SHOULD BE AN OPTION FOR
THES